there is a large number of people who support the
resistance of Ukraine, these are citizens of the Russian
Federation, they directly
participate in destroying these or other
military capabilities of the Russian
Federation on the territory of Russia, that is, they
directly attack military
objects or objects that have one or
another there  relation to the
military-industrial complex of the
Russian Federation, by the way, this is not
only about the border territories of Russia,
it is also far deep in the rear of the Russian
Federation, all this is being destroyed by the citizens of the
Russian Federation, they support
our struggle, but they are citizens of
Russia
[music]
first of all, the attacks of Ukraine are aimed at  in the
occupied territories, they have increased in
large numbers, including in relation to the
Crimean peninsula in relation to the Russian
Federation, this is the second component, there is an
increase in the number of attacks by
uninstalled drones launched from the
territory of the Russian Federation, and
the number of these attacks will increase
because, in principle, this is the stage of the war, this is the
third phase of the gradual transfer of combat forces  actions
on the territory of the Russian Federation
to lose. We are absolutely clear today
that we will destroy all
Russian objects and have been doing this for some time
in the occupied territories, including the
Crimean peninsula. In relation to Moscow, we once again
emphasize that light unmanned instruments are used there,
which are launched
from a short distance from the Central
Federal District  The partners of the Russian Federation
at the moment
understand that this war will no longer have a
compromise solution, that is, either we
destroy the capabilities of the
finality of the capabilities of Russia by military means, for
this we need the appropriate
tools, or this war will continue with
such aggression for some time, any
negotiation process if someone  does not
understand this, it will mean the capitulation of
Ukraine, the capitulation of democratic education
as a whole if
[music]
produced by the USA and also against the
Neptune ship rocket and a modified
shock variant of the
S200 anti-aircraft missile, except for Lava, destroyed 281
Ukrainian unmanned rocket
launchers, including one
Tu-141 rocket  swift as well as 29
Ukrainian
drones of the aircraft type in the western
regions of the Russian Federation forward from
August 25 to September 1 the
armed forces of the Russian Federation
inflicted five group strikes of
high-range long-range
air and sea-based weapons on the
control points of the
radio erotic technology center separation of operatives from the
object of the port infrastructure of
the place of surrender  munitions and western
models of weapons. And so the
armed forces of Ukraine were destroyed by the Central Committee of the
assembly without crew boats used by the
Kiev regime for terrorist
acts, anti-aircraft defense systems, rocket salvo
systems, armored vehicles, as
well as aviation
means of destruction of Western
production